hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play reunion okay
now the person who suggested this
actually made it very clear that I need
to take this game seriously um they just
said it over and over that I need to not
make stupid jokes about this so I'm
going to be doing a very serious let's
play here because this game might be
emotional or something along those lines
so I actually don't know a lot about it
so um it's made by um I don't know where
these people are from but mono Skaar
Abdullah Kanak ahmed alaa dad um so it's
obviously not American or any of the
typical game making countries but
hopefully it'll be just as good turn my
volume down just a little bit it's got
some nice music to it
yeah well lead alright so we got a kid
running away I'm just gonna assume
Waleed OH press space - Walid okay
well lead hello okay so Walid I hear a
snake is that bad
Walid what's going on here
okay this is really freaky because the
sound is very well done in this game I
don't know if you can tell but it's like
it's it's I've got really good
headphones so it's kind of pumping all
around me I just kind of I hear this
thumping of a heart okay I'm gonna
assume that sound is a very important
thing and I need to pay attention to it
what is that a mosque whoa what is that
oh it's a bear
ah oh it's good I was away from it oh
man
alright then press x to jason press
space - Walid okay I get an arrow every
time I pressed wall or I call out to
Walid so I guess I just got to find my
son he's why did he run away oh I didn't
even see that one it was hidden in with
the trees that was not fair snakes do
not
I didn't trees okay anyway I'm your
father
yeah I think he knows that and I don't
think that's your son I'm just gonna go
out on the lemons I'm just gonna say ah
it sounded like it was coming from up
above it actually does it really sounds
like it's coming from all over the place
and I don't know if you guys can tell
based on the YouTube compression but I
got a new microphone it's actually a UH
a shure sm7b it's an exceptionally high
quality microphone but it's kind of
wasted on youtube but it's mostly for me
and my purposes of doing more voice
acting stuff so just in case you were
interested in hearing about that how am
I supposed to get through I hear them
everywhere oh okay I just gotta take
this really slowly or else I'm never
gonna get there why did the kid run into
the woods come on son you're gonna get
eaten up by bears
answer me Waleed why the kids always got
to run away Oh what is that what in the
world is that haha okay let's go down I
hear a bear but I also hear something
something really bad over there haha I
don't know what that was but I'm not
getting closer to finding my son danger
sign number three okay alright this is
that like this games way of saying like
a save point so apparently there's
something was that like the demon
version of my son was I now supposed to
find that one god I hear I hear animals
all over the blue
oh god it's another one of those things
Jesus as creepy as hell can I cut
through those trees I don't think so
damnit I got I got to get through him
but I don't know how wait hang on I kind
of started in a different area maybe I
got maybe I gotta find that guy maybe I
have no idea I really don't know what
I'm doing here so apparently that was
not the answer
hey I don't know what I'm doing man I'm
just kind of freaked out it the snake
snake it's a snake oh come on I didn't
even get a chance this game is brutal
this game is unrelenting I'll get it
eventually though yeah bear is that a
bear doesn't quite sound like a bear
braw a mutated demonic bear okay I hear
something very close by and then snake
on the right demon on the left can i
thread the needle here okay I hear the
Sun oh my god the things a father does
for his child I guess oh my god okay
here the I hear a heart pounding in the
left ear
waleed here's something else that's a
new sound this forest is filled with
nightmares too many nightmares way too
many nightmares
okay I hear another one of those things
oh that is not a good thing oh he's
close okay I got to go down they're
closed they're closed they're really
close the hell are they oh my god I did
you know for being a simple game this is
awfully cross to phobic okay I found
something oh man creepy as hell
well now is that him
you
holy crap
for those of you who may not have
understood what just happened there oh
sorry I still have a cough holy crap
whoa that was something I I wasn't
expecting that
um what happened was I'm still trying to
process it but the Sun was running away
in the beginning because the father was
mentally ill that's why he was seeing
all those things in the woods and those
demons and those noises and he just
killed his son that is that is
ridiculous I mean it sends a message a
really important message true but Wow
that I I was not ready for that okay wow
that is just incredible seriously and I
didn't expect an actual message but this
is very serious yeah um it's very true
mental illness is big problem you know
it's not addressed as much as it should
be because you know the way society
works today we always think that oh he's
mentally ill you need to lock him up in
an asylum but no it's it's not
necessarily you need to recognize these
things before they happen or they
developers progress into I think like
that man
for a game it's rare that a game makes
me surprised like that and kind of feel
like really bad that I was playing that
father that was something but I mean
that's what games are about I mean they
explore different things besides just
funny and that's they can send a serious
message and I didn't know that this was
gonna be a serious this serious of a
let's play I would have joked a lot less
had I known but um seriously thank you
guys so much for watching thank you for
suggesting it because this doesn't mean
it's a bad game it was really
interesting because it made someone
sense that he was so warped in his
travel through the woods and why his kid
was running away in the first place that
was ah I didn't clue into that at all
man that was something okay so anyway
the link is in the description if you
want to check out this game for yourself
um you can read up on a mental illness
obviously this is trying to spread
message and then that's really cool that
it does and really really really kick me
and they got there but anyway that was
those well done
so uh hope you guys enjoyed this dope
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and if you got you know games that
are unorthodox that you want to suggest
to me that aren't necessarily you know
just purely scary or or comedy or
something like that you got a serious
message in the game you know I'd like to
play them they're they're just as
important as anything else so just take
these things seriously guys some things
aren't all jokes and some things aren't
all fun but uh some things do have a
very important message go anyway thank
you all so much for watching League
annotations and I will see you in the
next video bye-bye
grabbed me by the big throat
I'll break this Peter of death
hahaha
what are you doing either river styxx
roars in front
still injustice or